New York Mayor Bill DeBlasio enjoys
flying around his city by helicopter but
make no mistake he is a true warrior for
the climate and you can tell because
he's using taxpayer money to sue oil
companies over climate change
he puts other people's money where his
mouth is pretty clever ken mortars a
climate activists he said he'd go
further he says ok to break the law for
the sake of climate change Ken Ward
joins us tonight I can't thank for
coming on hey thanks for having me I
just heard you call somebody
what was it demagogue little I you know
why that was then this is now can
totally different segments different
guests I'm glad to see you if you're
wondering what I got myself into but
come on no no unless a little delicate
let me ask you this and I'm not gonna
call you that or hopefully anyone else
that ever again I hope but whatever but
why can the mayor of New York call
himself a warrior against climate change
if he uses a helicopter to get around a
city when he could take public
transportation oh you know we could yeah
those kinds of questions all the time
and I can't seem everyone of course but
no I think it is a very fair question I
think that we're trying to change an
entire system here partly you can do
that by your own behaviors right I think
that's exemplary and so yeah I would
think that anybody who's concerned about
climate change ought to be very
concerned about their own you know
carbon impact and at the same time we're
trying to achieve political change in
America as it is and it's very hard to
do that without you know burning some
fossil fuels sure I understand that I
mean that you know they're they're
practical limits to people's ability to
live out their beliefs but I I do think
it calls into question the sincerity of
a person who's framing the debate in
moral terms if he falls so far short in
other words if I'm a spokesman for PETA
but I you know operate a slaughterhouse
on the side I'm less believable does
that make sense
it totally does I don't think climate
change is being framed entirely in moral
terms it's being put in practical
pragmatic terms you know we're facing
the
cataclysmic climate change that has
moral implications but it's got you know
practical living implications right so
you know so how is it that in pursuit of
living out your opinions on climate
change you believe you ought to be
allowed to violate the law I'm not sure
I'd say I want to be allowed to violate
the law well I want what I believe is
that in taking the actions such as we
recently did when we faced charges and
when we go to court it is appropriate
for us to be able to explain to the jury
why we did you know what we did and to
be able to call some expert witnesses
that would testify to the facts as we
understand them that's it I mean that's
not I mean but that's not really an act
of conscience then I mean typically when
people protest what they think is an
unjust system and are punished for it
they say part of the action part of the
reason it's a noble action is because
they accept the consequences and say yes
I know what's against the law did it
anyway why don't you do that yeah no I'm
not trying to get off here certainly
anybody who engages in direct action if
you're going to stand you know stand
there and get arrested as with the
expectation that you may well be
punished for it I mean in the action
that I did after two trials I was
convicted of burglary
I'm not protesting burglary I've had my
house broken into I think burglary rows
are good I all I'm saying is I'd like to
be able to explain to the jury why I did
what I did and call some experts and
then it's up to them do you think they
got a shot and decides I mean I've now
said no I understand I understand that
did but does this right you think apply
to others do you think the guy who shot
George Tiller the abortionist or any of
the other abortionist we've been
murdered by anti-abortion activists
oughta ought to be able to explain their
position to a jury and perhaps that
would be exculpatory I do not think this
should be an easy process by any means
it is a difficult one rarely do judges
allow you know presenting a necessity
offense if you
do you present the necessity offense
there's some really high hurdles that a
you know that you have to and I think
that's appropriate
I don't you think anti-abortion
activists should be allowed to do that
though I've well first of all the
example that you mentioned was violent I
am committed to non-violence about
blocking a clinic so blocking a clinic I
think that if people believe that this
is you know what actually I think the
the pro-life movement is pretty
comparable in a lot of ways to the
political situation that climate
activists face which is a insoluble
problem that the mainstream politics and
in this case both parties are not
dealing with though that's the classic
situation all right well that's that
that seems like a fair that's a fair
position Thank You Kent thanks for that
position yes nice to have you on